[Musique]
Jean-Marie ginbert bonjour bonjour merci
de nous recevoir dans cet endroit
prestigieux nous sommes à l'espace
richot qui est l'ancienne chapelle de
l'hôpital royal tout à fait entièrement
restaurée depuis peu depuis très peu
parce qu'elle est ouverte depuis le mois
d'avril voilà donc c'est un lieu
magnifique qui va servir de comment dire
de lieu d'exposition de de scène un lieu
de culture
plusdisciplinaire très
ouvertou au cœur de ville donc
Jean-Marie Guilbert c'est votre premier
Mois Molière puisque vous êtes arrivé il
y a peu à la ville au à la direction des
affaires culturelles de la ville de
versaill voilà euh qu'est-ce que ça
fait ça fait très très très plaisir très
plaisir déjà très plaisir d'abord par
que c'est quand même une ville
formidable et avec un évidemment un
prestige culturel énorme et puis c'est
une ville très vivante sur le plan
culturel il y a énormément de choses à
faire et puis il y a quelques joyaux
quelques belles pépites en particulier
bah le mois Molère ça sera mon premier
d' voilà et donc c'est on peut dire
c'est l'événement phare ah oui c'est le
plus important c'est plus visible c'est
celui qui qui touche le plus le le plus
grand nombre de public qui occupe le
plus la ville c'est quand même un
moisour auin plus de 300 représentations
dans pratiquement tous les lieux de la
ville hein je crois pas qu'il y a un
lieu qui soit épargné par le MO Molière
ça va du tennis club à ici hein tout
nouveau lieux d'ailleurs expérimenté à
cette occasion des jardins les parcs du
théâtre du C oui parce qu'en fait le but
du jeu c'est d'amener le théâtre au
spectateurs quelqu que par un peu comme
la coméarté aller à la rencontre du
spectateur aussi c'est c'est vraiment le
principe qui est qui est fondateur de ce
de ce festival totalement à part depuis
sa création il y a 20 ans par Françoise
masierre voilà ça il a été créé en 96
par Françoise masierre alors direc non
pas directeur non directeur c'est vous
lui François maer il était adjoint à la
Culture quand il a créé ce fameux
festival tout à fait c'est donc la 20e
édition voilà et donc le but comme vous
dites c'est euh de populariser le
théâtre de de le faire partager au
maximum de personnes c'est c'est l'idée
vraiment du moi j'aime bien cette
expression je crois que le le maire là
François demasier la reprend volontiers
à son compte c'est l'idée de l'élitisme
pour tous c'est-à-dire véritablement oui
le meilleur pour tout le monde tous les
publics d'où d'où l'importance de de
faire du spectacle du Théâtre beaucoup
mais pas seulement d'ailleurs alors
justement si on peut s'arrêter 2
secondes finalement quatre arts sont euh
proposés oui à savoir donc le théâtre
bien évidemment la danse évidemment la
musique et les arts du cirque et quelque
part ça rappelle que Versailles est la
ville fondatrice de de de la comédie
balai de l' Molière l'art total voilà et
euh c'est ce qu'on va retrouver donc
pendant ce mois entier c'est vraiment
une inspiration assez riche
puisqueeffectivement c'est une
proposition d'abord très variée pour
tous les publics hein vraiment j'insiste
sur point tous les goûts tous les
publics ça va du du du plus jeune du
plus jeune au plus âgé ça va y compris
toucher des publics qu'on peut qualifier
d'empêcher alors qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire ces publics empêchés c'est
un ce sont des publics dont on peut
considérer que leur leur vocation à à à
être touché par la culture est pas
forcément spontané qu'ils que l'obstacle
soit pour certains ça peut être social
hein mais pour d'autres c'est vraiment
des empêchements qui sont liés soit à un
handicap par exemple soit tout
simplement au fait qu'ils ne puissent
pas sortir des lieux qu'ils
occupent on pense à des personnes âgées
par exemple hein c'est important d'aller
à leur rencontre dans des dans des dans
des maisons de retraite par exemple
d'accord mais on pense compris à des
personnes qui sont carrément incarcéré
puisque versaill a une prison de femme
et que cette prison de femme elle est
concernée aussi par le théâtre on va
faire du théâtre dans la maison d'arrêt
l'ORS du Mois Molière exactement elles
vont avoir droit à des spectacles
interne exctement exactement c'est quand
même voilà une proposition je pense que
ce qui est ce qui est fondateur et
fondamental dans le mè c'est la
générosité qui est derrière c'est
vraiment vraiment une grande générosité
culturelle faut quand même savoir que
cette générosité saccompagne d'ailleurs
d'une grande
gratuité 60 % spectacles sont gratuits
son
gratuit oui on peut citer quelques
chiffres puisquon va par là par exemple
on attend 100000 spectateurs oui c'est
c'est la moyenne c'est en augmentation
c'est en augmentation 65 lieux de
représentation qu'est-ce que j'oublie
SEP compagnies en résidence plus de 300
représentations dans tout dans tout
versaill pendant 30 jours pendant 30
jours VO c'est une forme de Marathon le
MI c'est c'est une marathon pour
spectateur c'est un marathon aussi pour
nous d'Ille h alors comment vous
fonctionnez donc ces sept compagnies en
résidence à versaill euh déjà qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire être en résidence c'est
quelque chose de très important ces
compagn en résidence parce que c'est un
peu le le le le noyau du Mois Molière
c'est c'est quelque chose qui s'est
produit au fil du temps avec des elles
sont pas arrivées tout de suite elles
sont arrivées d'abord parce qu'elles ont
elles ont aimé le moimolière en y
participant euh elles ont été amené du
coup à vouloir s'encrer dans le
territoire puis on les a quand même
beaucoup beaucoup accompagné beaucoup
incités à le faire c'est vrai là aussi
une volonté de de François de maer très
forte que de faire en sorte que le M ce
soit pas une bulle ce soit pas un
événement qui pendant un mois va animer
toute la ville et puis pouf après c'est
fini on en parle plus des ones qui se
propagent tout exctement et le fait
d'avoir ces compagnes en résidence
d'abord ça nous garanti donc en
résidence pardon ça veut dire son ve
dire qu'elles sont toute l'année à versa
elles ont un lieu de travail un lieu qui
leur est destiné dans lequel ell pu
elles peuvent vraiment travailler elles
peuvent c'est pas forcément des lieux de
travail au sens elles produisent pas
forcément des spectacles mais elles ont
un lieu où elles peuvent vraiment
s'ancrer travailler avoir tout
simplement une adresse administratif des
bureaux qui leur permet véritablement de
travailler travailler à versaill et pas
seulement parce que elles existent comme
ça ell ça leur permet véritablement
d'être totalement inscrit dans un
paysage et Dieu sait si c'est difficile
pour des compagnies d'exister
aujourd'hui hein donc c'est une aide
finalement considérable qu'on leur
apporte qui est pas forcément une aide
financière le simple fait de leur
fournir un lieu c'est déjà les aider les
inscrire évidemment au Mois Molière
c'est aussi les
aider voilà en contrepartie elles vont
elles vont travailler avec nous elles
vont justement travailler toute l'année
avec les publics scolaires dans les dans
les dans les quartiers un peu spécialis
un peu un peu difficile d'accès elles
vont aller travailler avec les personnes
âgées elles vont fournir en fait tout un
travail à l'année qui leur est utile
parce qu'elle répète elle prépar leur
production pour le Molière et puis pas
seulement parce que le Mois Molière faut
pas oublier que les créations du
moisolière pour certaines d'entre elles
elles vont circuler après oui justement
il y a une vingtaine de créations qui
partent partentite NOTAM off d'AV
d'Avignon et qui peuvent partir ensuite
en tourner dans à travers le monde enfin
bah pour prendre un exemple notre grand
Carlo booso qui est quand même le le qui
est le le patron appelonsle appelons-le
comme ça le grand Capitan de l'Académie
Internationale des Arts du spectacle et
bien là dans quelques jours il sera à
Syracuse pour participer à un festival
de Coméd d'art et c'est sa spécialité
c'est aussi des de fabrique duolière cet
attachement à la à la à la gestuelle
théâtrale cette articulation entre le
texte le geste le corpsin et c'est vrai
que c'est quelque chose de très très
important que d'être lisible aussi dans
ce qu'on produit et d'être d'avoir
choisi ce territoire là qui CELI de la
Comédia de l'art qui est un art à la
fois classique et populaire hein qui est
capable véritablement de de franchir les
frontières que le le le rapport parfois
direct au texte dans son exigence
euh ça passe pas toujours très très bien
pas toujours si facilement là on est sur
des des capacités à toucher des publics
encore une fois ça marche avec les
enfants mais c'est extraordinaire de de
voir un spectacle de Comé d'Arté il y a
notamment parmi les production vous avez
un un Capitaine Fracasse c'est une
adaptation libre du texte de de Gautier
c'est juste c'est de 7 à 77 ans quoi ça
Mar vous ah oui beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup c'est un grand enfantou et
sinon alors donc on a deux lieux
prestigieux et nouveau donc là où nous
sommes aujourd'hui voilà l'espace richot
qui va accueillir un cycle racine entre
autres alors là c'est un c'est une
proposition très ambitieuse pour le coup
on parlait justement de cette capacité à
être à introduire des textes parfois
exig donc Jean-Luc genner qui a s'est
lancé dansintégrale le mur en scène
pardon Jean-Luc genner qui qui est
officié au Théâtre du Nord-Ouest à Paris
s'est lancé lui dans une intégrale des
textes de Racine alors il va pas faire
intégrale à Versailles pour le moolère
il en fera quatre ici dans ses murs d'
et on pense que Racine ici ça va
raisonner un peu par de manière un peu
particulière ou d'accord et on a aussi
la caserne de croix un endroit qu'on
appelle la retonde qui vient touj
inauguré le 18 mai donc c'était c'était
2 jours voilà la retonde dans la caserne
de croix va accueillir pour la première
fois le théâtre de des universités
populaires créé par Michel hfrey et
Jean-Claude ID et Jean-Claude idé tout à
fait voilà alors qu'est-ce qu'on nous
propose à ce alors ça c'est aussi c'est
une c'est une double première en fait
puisque cette salle elle vient tout
juste d'être inauguré c'est une salle
contemporaine dans un milieu patrimonial
absolument somptueux parce que l'ancien
ancienne retonde de de cavalerie du 18e
siècle c'est quoi une retonde de
cavalerie en fait le c'est un manèage à
chevau c'est vraiment d' d'ù d'ù cette
forme circulaire qui permetta tout
simplement de faire chauffer les chevaux
d'accord voilà OK et c'est un lieu
magique alors ouvert à ciel ouvert et
dans cette à proximité immédiate
l'architecte Clément vergeli qui qui est
un jeune architecte a eu l'intelligence
d'inscrire un bâtiment qui est un bijou
contemporain une magnifique salle de
spectacle entre autres ça ne sera pas
que ça mais qu'on va expérimenter pour
le mamolière avec des lectures
effectivement de texte contemporain euh
c'est une proposition ambitieuse c'est
la première fois que les universités
populaires du théâtre se produisentve
Versailles j'espère qu'il y aura une
suite on verra si le public est aussi
enthousiaste que nous mais avec quelques
très belles propositions dont un texte
d'ailleurs de Jean-Claude idé autour de
saint-exupéri et du Petit
Prince qui qui est une très belle
proposition donc juste pour conclure 1er
juin 30 juin le 1er juin c'est Francis
Perin qui a était le témoin du premier
mois Molière et témoin au baptême lui
hein voilà et acteur aussi voilà qui va
jouer tout son propre spectacle Molière
malgré moi aux grandes écuries programme
tout un programme pour un Mo Molière
exactement et le 30 juin ça va être
cluturé par l'école des femme oui
Molière oblige he moliè oblige avec un
jeune acteur dont on entend de plus en
plus parler à savoir Martin loisillon
voilà donc toutes les génération il en a
pour tous les goûts pour tout le monde
oui et puis avec cette cette volonté
vraiment d'être d'être résolument
créatif je crois que ce qui c'est l'un
des très maîes mots de du moolière c'est
effectivement de mettre la création à
l'honneur mais une création accessible
d'accord c'est on n'est pas dans le
geste on n'est pas dans le dans
lesesbrouf on est véritablement dans
cette volonté de parler à tous à tous
les Versaillais et pas seulement on
espère non j'imagine que ça attire des
gens deoui oui ça Trine un public très
large qui vient de moins de tout l'île
de France et faut quand même imaginer
que c'est finalement le premier des
grands festivals d'été déjà vous ouvrez
la saisonon on ouvre la saison on ouvre
la saison donc c'est un moment
ok donc il a qui a souhaiter juste qu'il
fasse beau alors ça il faut vraiment
croiser il y a quand même beaucoup de
spectacles en plein air donc s'il pleut
c'est une catastrophe mais on a moyen de
se replier oui oui je sais mais même les
gens sont tellement passionnés qui
viennent quand même oui on a toujours
des solutions toujours même même dans
les grandes écuries dans les dans la
cour on arrive à trouver une solution
entre client bon ben écoutez c'est
chance ce programme alors Jean-Marie
nibert je vous laisse le mot de la fin
rendez-vous avec Molière mais pas
seulement avec tous les auteurs avec
Victor Hugo au théâtre montencier avec
l'OP des Vega aux grandes écuries avec
racin i hein et puis puis énormément
d'autres plaisirs à venir qu'on retrouve
détaillé làdedans à trouver partout dans
les bonnes dans les bonnes boutiques la
maison du Molière au carré la farine qui
est vraiment l'endroit où on a toute
l'information et du marché not
n'oublions pas nos bénévoles 200
bénévoles pour le Molière donc vous les
retrouverez pour une partie d'entre eux
dès aujourd'hui à la maison
[Musique]
duière